qui mord les négociations ont commencé
après un discours d'accueil une
allocution du président turc recep
tayyip erdogan qui a depuis quitté le
palais de dolmabahçe que vous voyez
derrière moi pour se rendre en
ouzbékistan où il est attendu pour une
visite de deux jours et il a passé le
relais à son chef de la diplomatie me
luciano chauloux qui a pour charge de
faciliter les discussions mais le
président turc dans son intervention a
voulu souligner la nuance nous ne sommes
pas médiateur at il dit nous sommes
simplement là pour faciliter les
discussions le président turc a dit
qu'il était temps maintenant que des
discussions produisent des effets
concrets il appelle ses deux voisins à
s'entendre à créer un à s'entendre mois
sur un consensus qui pourrait servir de
base pour un accord de paix plus durable
et je dis que personne n'est gagnant à
continuer les combats et que tout le
monde serait gagnant à faire la paix
selon lui la prochaine étape sera une
rencontre directe entre les deux
présidents a dance qui est poutine et il
propose que cette rencontre si elle a
lieu et bien se fasse en turquie et puis
il a fini son adresse en demandant à aux
deux délégations de transmettre de sa
part ses meilleurs sentiments à ces deux
chers amis et voisins se sont ce sont
ses mots lé président poutine et élèves
qui donc après son intervention elle les
négociations ont commencé d'abord avec
un tête à tête entre les deux chefs des
délégations qui doit toujours être en
cours et ce tête à tête sera suivi par
des discussions entre les deux
délégations en groupe concrètement
ludovit que va-t-on se dire aujourd'hui
écoutez si on en croit le chef de la
diplomatie ukrainienne mis trop cool et
baky qui s'exprimait à la télévision
nationale ukrainienne hier il a dit le
programme minimum attendu c'est les
questions humanitaires donc on peut on
peut imaginer que c'est surtout autour
de la question humanitaire à marioupol 1
que qu'il y aura des discussions pour la
mise en place de couloirs humanitaires
de cette ville autour de cette ville
assiégée et après il a dit le programme
maximum ce serait un accord de paix mais
ça serait évidemment le programme le
plus ambitieux les négociateurs
ukrainiens eux mêmes ont dit qu'ils ne
s'attendaient pas à des avancées
majeures après la différence qui a
aujourd'hui avec la dernière fois où les
ukrainiens et les russes se sont
rencontrés physiquement c'est la
situation sur le terrain qui est quand
même évolué et qui semble évoluer de
manière plus favorable à l ukraine avec
une russie qui semble vraiment
s'embourber donc ça ça doit probablement
aussi ça devrait probablement se
réfléter dans les négociations il ya des
lignes rouges pour les négociateurs
ukrainiens pas question parlait de
changement de régime ou de changement de
pouvoir à kiev pas question de toucher à
l'intégrité territoriale
de le de l'ukraine et donc de concéder
les territoires donc on parlera
humanitaire et peut-être aussi de la
question de la neutralité de l'ukraine
et de sa dénucléarisation